hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of Science
and Technology
and I see all kinds of saved up
questions here so let me see what uh
what I can address
uh there's one from Lola here
are the stars and constellations we see
today uh the same that was seen by
ancient civilizations who first studied
them do star positions ever change so
that's kind of a combination of uh uh
history
and um
uh
uh and science so first question is
about star constellations and their
positions so there is so-called proper
motion of stars which means stars do
move around uh the the and the Stars
which are closer to us we notice the
emotion more than we notice the motion
of stars further away there are some
stars that are pretty bright
because they are intrinsically their
absolute magnitude as stars is very high
and even though they're a long way away
the fact that their their absolute
magnitude is high means that their
relative magnitude the perceived
brightness of those stars is still
pretty high so when we see a
constellation there could be 10 stars in
the constellation and some of them are
very near to us and some of them are
very very far away the ones that are
very far away were unlikely to see
Motion in the ones that are near us we
will see motion
so
uh the for the nearest Stars there's
definitely visible motion that's
happened for example since Antiquity to
today
um and there are definitely some changes
in fact in wolfen Alpha I remember we
put in the data on proper motion and you
can actually see constellations at
different times in history there and
there are sort of random stars in the
constellation that will move around
because they happen to be closer to us
now in terms of so yes there are some
changes there
there's also
um one of the questions that's a sort of
a typical History of Science question is
uh hipparchus made a star catalog
Ptolemy made a more famous star catalog
I think ptolemus was like in the First
Century A.D
hippocuses few centuries BC
and uh they were in in um uh and so one
of the questions that's been around in
history of science for a long time is
did Ptolemy plagiarize hippocus
and um uh
the um uh the thing that um uh you might
be able to tell is if the stars would
have moved between the time of hippocus
and the time of Ptolemy would that be a
giveaway that Ptolemy just plagiarized
to pakis's Star catalog and the answer
is actually one of my my kids
Christopher
um actually did some work on the kind of
the detailed statistics of kind of uh
the the star catalog of Ptolemy versus
the parkas and I as I recall the
conclusion was it's kind of on the edge
you can't quite tell it's uh it's kind
of like um from the information
available it's like yeah Ptolemy could
have got his stuff from hibachus and the
Stars could have moved slightly over
those couple of hundred years
um or he could have observed them
separately but but uh uh you know it was
kind of not not obvious
but so
in terms of so now the next question is
if you look at the constellations that
we have today
um and that we pick out you know whether
it's uh you know the constellation I
don't know
uh cygnus you know Virgo whatever all
the various constellations the signs of
the zodiac the the the make these
constellations
um do we pick out the same sort of
patterns of stars as people did in
ancient times Well we inherited the
Babylonian constellations the
constellations that we have were
basically picked up by the Babylonians
in ancient China for example different
constellations were picked out just you
know the witch Stars went with which
stars just completely different it's
kind of an interesting test of kind of
the perception of things by different
civilizations of you know you've got
this random array of stars how do you
join the dots to pick out different uh
different kinds of Critters and
obviously the constellations that we
have now are ones that uh you know are
things like you know water bearers and
things like this which are fine things
of antiquity not so commonly seen in
many most parts of the world today
um I actually don't know for the
southern Stars I actually don't know
where the constellations which
civilization picked out the
constellations of the stars that can
only be seen in uh in the southern
hemisphere because that obviously wasn't
the Babylonians because they didn't uh
they didn't get to that part of the
world
um so I don't know exactly how that how
that worked out but yeah so I think um
the uh
um
uh that's that's the story of that and I
mean we know that um uh many
aspects of the stars that we have today
uh will have moved Polaris well the the
the you know will it be the North Pole
star forever
um no it's it's moving
um and uh other kinds of features of you
know the Big Dipper or what in British
English is called the plow
um the uh that constellation of stars
will not have the shape it does at some
time in the future
now
um there's also another effect is the
procession of the equinoxes the fact
that the Earth is uh processing like a
top on its axis
um it's 23 degree tilt relative to the
plane in which it orbits the sun there
is procession of that every 23 000 years
I think and so that's a that's a
substantial difference in the
constellations that we see in a
particular place in the northern
hemisphere for example from
in Antiquity because that's you know
Antiquity is now you know let's say
three thousand years that's a decent
fraction of the of the rotation period
of the procession of the equinoxes
um and uh so that's another phenomenon I
mean in terms of what we'll be seeing in
the past what we've seen in the future
uh if you go back to really ancient
times things like there's the question
of will eclipses have worked the same
way I mean right now a total solar
eclipse there's this sort of remarkable
fact that the disk of the Moon more or
less exactly covers the disc of the sun
clearly uh you know if we were living on
Mars for example the couple of
satellites from us and demos there
um they are their sizes relative to the
disk of the sun they're tiny relative to
the disc of the sun
um in that case the moon you know in
general in our solar system our moon is
a very big moon relative to the uh the
size of our planet and um it's but it's
gradually getting further and further
away from the earth So eventually the
the moon the disc of the moon will no
longer cover the disc of the sun when
viewed from the Earth but in the time of
the dinosaurs or something there will be
you know you could have many it will be
much easier to have a total eclipse
because uh the disc of the moon was much
bigger relative to the disc of the sun
because the moon was proportionally
closer to the Earth which will have led
to all kinds of other effects about
tides and all sorts of other features
and and the in a sense the reason the
Moon is getting further away has to do
with the fact that there is some tidal
defamation
um that is slowly energy is being
dissipated by that
anyway uh let's see
um
let's see Andrew is asking what do you
make of the relationship between
rhetoric and math they're held in Contra
distinction but I'm thinking the
relation uh between rhetorical invention
and Greg treyson's idea of math
creativity boy I'm not completely sure
I've known Greg for like 40 years uh
quite well but I'm not sure I know
exactly what his idea of math creative
is but maybe I can guess
um
you know
it's worth remembering rhetoric
back in Antiquity people will study
rhetoric they would study
um uh you know they they'd um
that was
well in the Middle Ages it's kind of
rhetoric logic
math these were things that were studied
uh
as a
as a mechanism for um uh sort of this
idea of there is a definite pattern to
arguments that you can give which is
some part of the story of rhetoric that
became a um
uh that idea of the patterning of
arguments is what Aristotle turned into
logic you know Aristotle kind of lifted
this formal structure of logic out of
the repeated patterns of rhetoric that
that he saw
um I'm not sure
I mean in a sense
logic is a formalization of rhetoric
math is another thing that you can kind
of lift out of language I mean we could
say just as a matter of plain language
if I've got two ducks and a duck then
I'll have three ducks and I can say that
just linguistically but then I can kind
of lift out of that this two plus one
equals three kind of formal structure
what math did was it built this very
tall tower of formalism on top of what
would otherwise be just kind of
linguistic statements and that's been
the typical story of science uh
particularly post the 1600s is this idea
of can we make this kind of precise
rule-based structure that kind of
ascends above the things that we can
describe in ordinary language I mean if
you look at theories of physics for
example from Antiquity they were always
described in an ordinary language it's
like you know the atoms the void the uh
this and that and the other these were
just matters of ordinary language nobody
was saying and then we have this precise
kind of mathematical structure that
represents an atom or represents the
void if they had done that many things
that were discovered only many many
centuries later would have been
discovered back then but at the time the
way of describing the world that people
imagined was a linguistic narrative way
of describing the world in terms of
words and this idea of a formal way of
describing the world that really was
something that I would say arose in
serious terms in the 1600s now there
have been some precursors of that for
example with the geometry and Euclid and
so on there was this idea of a a formal
triangle or something
different from the actual triangle that
you might draw in the sand or some such
other thing the idea that there was a
formal version of that and that's
something that Plato and other people
were very into this idea of a kind of a
formalization of things that that they
saw particularly in the case of geometry
geometry was the place where there was
first this idea of sort of idealization
of of things as the ideal triangle as
opposed to the actual triangle and so on
now I think
um
gosh the notion of of the extent to
which you know you talk about things in
the world you write factual text to
write fictional texts the concept that
you could write a fictional test or your
text or you could you just write about
anything
that's a question of to what extent does
that map into our thinking about math
and that sort of has to do with the
question of relates to the question
about whether math is invented or
discovered this whole set of questions
about whether we can just make up math
about anything or whether math is
somehow tied to something about either
us or about the world in which we live I
think that's been greatly clarified by
things I've done in recent times about
the physicalization of matter
mathematics but we can kind of go
through a little bit of that I mean so
Euclid for example in his time he
thought his geometry he did arithmetic
and things as well he thought those were
things where they were kind of uh sort
of formal ABS abstractions of things
about the world when he said two
parallel lines will never cross he was
imagining two lines that you would
actually draw in the sand and they would
actually never cross
and I think much as Aristotle was
imagining us he talked about logic of p
and Q and so on uh not that he quite did
it that way but but that's the modern
version of it um you know he was
thinking about that as it's really a
sentence in Greek or whatever but there
are these pieces of it you can identify
in this kind of formalized way so you
know back in those days the idea was
take the world as as we experience it
whether it's natural language whether
it's geometry of things drawn in the
sand and so on and Abstract from that
something which we can discuss in a more
formal way in a way that doesn't depend
on the details of whether the stick that
we used to draw the thing in the sand
was was big or small or whatever else
so that was kind of the the idea of of
how mathematics would would uh this sort
of abstraction of the real world then we
go two Millennia later
and we go to the 1800s and we go to the
early 1800s when people were starting to
say well wait a minute you know do we
really have to build math that way so
for example do parallel lines ever cross
lobachevsky and so on in the 1830s I
think was starting to say no no we can
actually imagine a space where parallel
lines do cross
um and a curved space where parallel
lines crossed this thing about parallel
lines not Crossing is really just a an
axiom that Euclid is choosing based on
the experience of the world as the world
exists it doesn't have to be that way
similarly galwa same time 1830s uh
talking about things like group Theory
where it's like Well normally we have
you know a times b equals B times a but
if these are elements of this abstract
group that commutativity probably
doesn't have to be true same with with
Hamilton talking about quaternions same
around the same time uh same issue and
then soon thereafter Bool George boole
talking about Boolean algebra another
example of where we have something
that's sort of qualitatively like
ordinary algebra but it doesn't behave
ordinary algebra is an abstraction of
dealing with numbers but this is has the
kind of the character of algebra but
it's not about ordinary numbers because
things are commutative and you have
different rules and so on so that kind
of turned into by the by the 1870s 1880s
people like got love Fraga saying well
wait a minute what really is mathematics
what is uh you know is it just an
arbitrarily chosen set of axioms that we
then propagate forwards with rules
and you know Fraga had the interest in
in saying well is it really the case
that what's underneath mathematics is
just logic and then we we put on top of
logic certain assumed axioms from which
we can build anything we want
and then that kind of uh there were
other people involved Giuseppe piano was
another person
um and then David Hilbert uh sort of a
big figure in the late end of the 1800s
um who kind of really had this idea that
mathematics should be a formalized thing
where it's just you write down axioms
you prove theorems Hilbert's big break
and I think 1870s is sort of big first
big Discovery was a non-constructive
proof so normally when you make proofs
you say you know there's this
possibility there's this thing but if
you say this thing can exist
you can in a constructive proof you can
say and here it is I can show it to you
the number 13 has this property but
Hilbert gave a proof which was
non-constructive that is he could show
that something was true without ever
being able to produce the thing that
made it true and at first people were
very surprised by that but that was kind
of the beginning of Hilbert's approach
to this formalistic way of doing
mathematics so by 1900 or so Hilbert was
talking about the idea of well
mathematics is just you specify rules
and you just go forward with those rules
and he said you know we could Define a
mathematics in terms of tables and
chairs doesn't matter it doesn't have to
be numbers it doesn't have to be this
just a formal set of rules and so this
was the idea that that um that he kind
of had this notion that there was a
mechanical way of deciding everything of
solving the so-called decision problem
of of making any mathematical statement
be something that you could just
mechanistically decide from the
underlying axioms of mathematics which
by the way he implied you could pick the
axioms however you want it now then
girdle came along 1931 and showed that
this idea that there was a mechanical
way to get to any any theorem of
mathematics in a finite number of steps
that wasn't true that was the point of
Google's theorem that turns into in
modern times computational
irreducibility and lots of other ideas
that there isn't a finite path
necessarily even given that you know the
axioms there's no guarantee that a
particular theorem is is inaccessible
you can there might always be a longer
path to reach that theorem there's no
upper bound on how long a path you might
need now girdle part of his reason for
coming up with girdles theorem was he
wanted to blow up Hilbert's idea of a
formalistic mathematics he believed more
in sort of Plato's idea of mathematics
that there is some true mathematical
reality there's a there's a concrete
thing that is mathematical truth and we
when we do mathematics are merely
discovering that abstract concrete truth
that mathematics isn't in in Euclid's in
in girdle's view or Plato's view that
mathematics is its own thing with its
own reality having nothing to do with
the particular details of our physical
universe and so on
so so girdle and sort of blowing up
Hilbert's program kind of had the idea
that he was going back to a more
platonic view where there is a a real
existing thing that is mathematics which
we with our human brains and so on get
to sample pieces of okay so segwaying to
much more modern times and the results
of our physics project and the idea of
this thing we call the rouliad which is
the entangled limit of all possible
computations
and that one of the things that this is
now a couple years ago
um
this idea that within the rouliad within
the entangled limit of all possible
computations are all possible
mathematical theorems and all possible
proof paths for all of those theorems
and the question is then what do we do
when we do mathematics well what we do
when we do mathematics is we're
essentially sampling that really ad we
are observers of the rouliad as when we
do mathematics sampling pieces of what
exists out there in this in this limit
of all possible computations okay the
really interesting thing is that rouliad
is the same thing that underlies
physical reality as physical observers
of the universe we're doing the same
kind of thing we're sampling a little
piece of the rouliad that corresponds to
our physical characteristics as
observers and experiences of the
universe so the the really surprising
thing it kind of surprised me is the
realization that physics and Mathematics
are at the at the lowest level the same
thing they're both made of the rouliad
there is only one rule ad and if you
believe that the physical Universe
exists whatever sense you believe the
physical Universe exists so also the
mathematical Universe has to exist
and then the question is well are the
laws of physics how do they depend on
our character as observers is something
I've worked on a lot that the fact that
we observe physics the way we observe
physics to be with gravity and quantum
mechanics and so on is a consequence of
the fact that we are observers who have
the characteristics that we have we're
computationally bounded we believe we're
persistent in time those kinds of things
that that characteristic of us as
observers implies that we must
experience the laws of physics as we
experience them it it but that
characteristic of us as observers we're
we are the con we are what is what
underlies the physical world is this
rouliad which has all these
possibilities in it but the way we
sample rouliad is such that we must
observe the laws of physics that we
observe so what does that mean for
mathematics what it means for
mathematics is we are mathematical
observers with the same kinds of
constraints we have finite Minds
Etc et cetera Etc we have to experience
mathematics through our finite Minds
that puts constraints on the ways in
which we can sample the rule out in
effect it puts constraints in the end on
the kinds of axioms that we can
attribute to mathematics and have us
humans be able to coherently do
mathematics it could be the case that we
would make up these axioms and every
time we wanted to conclude something
about mathematics we'd have to go down
and be grunting around at the very
axiomatic level that's not how
mathematics actually works there's a
higher level experience of mathematics
it's kind of like we can experience not
the molecules bouncing around in the
room but the air currents it's the same
kind of thing in mathematics we can
experience not the very low level sub
axiomatic foundations but instead this
kind of higher level aesthetic kind of
thing that is the level that
mathematicians typically experience
things at and the fact that that's the
level we experience things at is a
consequence of our characteristics
observers so it ends up being the case
that I don't think it's true that there
are arbitrary axioms that we might
choose there are axons which if we chose
them we wouldn't have a coherent view of
mathematics mathematics would kind of
get shredded and and I think they're
probably things that um and so this
question of sort of what to what extent
can we just go off and just pick
mathematics at random the answer is
there will be constraints there may even
be constraints that we're seeing right
now of of sort of questions like the
Continuum hypothesis which is an axiom
that you kind of seems like you can take
it or leave it but that's probably not
true it's probably the case that one
branch of that is the one leads to kind
of human sort of sampleable mathematics
and another does not so that was a
rather long and Technical uh discussion
of that point
um
let's see
oh yes there was a comment from Jimmy
here commenting on my earlier uh answer
about
um uh about whether the heavens
uh the stars and so on are the way they
are the same way as they were in
Antiquity and commenting on on novas and
comets and things
um I would say that the uh supernovas
stars exploding definitely a change uh
you know the Crab Nebula in 1054 was one
example of a of a star that um I don't
know how bright that star was before it
exploded I mean when it did explode I
think it was it made the night sky
bright for like three days or something
um and it was kind of hard to miss
um I think there are
uh in the next 10 million years there
are some fairly nearby supernovas that
will happen but the time scales are
pretty long I mean you know there could
be a supernova next week we wouldn't
know it
um but uh
it's not something where any of the
really nearby stars to us
um is is going to do that kind of
anytime soon I mean there are if we look
at other galaxies we certainly see
supernovas but that's not something you
see in the night sky relevant to to uh
to constellations and such like
um the the question of of um
uh well comets that was you know
wandering stars and so on that was a a
very critical piece of the surprise of
the kind of the constancy of the heavens
I mean the fact is that this idea that
the heavens are perfect
and constant is an important kind of
foundational idea in both mathematics
and theology in Antiquity and the fact
that things like that the figure of the
moon or the sun is a perfect circle that
was something where that notion of
perfection was important in the view of
kind of the Ethereal realm as distinct
from the realm of the uh of things
terrestrial things and things created by
humans which have this imperfection I
wouldn't be surprised if some of the
thinking about theological kinds of
ideas really was a consequence of the
fact that gosh you can look up in the
sky and the Moon is a perfect circle and
that's uh and that that that sort of
perfection in the heavens is something
that probably played quite big in the
kind of the view of a realm of kind of
things above what we humans can do
but uh and so when when a you know a new
star showed up as a comet or something
that was kind of a big deal and
obviously there are things like Halley's
Comet which had a storied history I mean
it was um uh I think it it showed up um
when William the Conqueror was um uh
conquering England in 1066 and uh well
maybe when he was uh I know it's in the
Bao tapestry which is a a sort of
recording of the history of the Norman
conquest and um uh that it shows up and
some I forget when it's actually when
when sort of uh uh William was going to
England or whether it was right before
but anyway it shows up and and then uh
you know Halle Halle Edmund Halley was
uh
um a kind of Statesman and uh science
interested Statesman in the uh late
1600s and uh that Comet was named after
him and one of the things that was of
great interest in those days was to
explain comments what were they what was
their did they have orbits how do their
orbits work and that was one of the big
things that Isaac Newton did that led
eventually to his principia Mathematica
was explaining the motion of
particularly Halley's Comet and that was
significant because Halle was at that
time I think the president of the Royal
Society in England and um was uh
persuaded uh you know told Newton you
really have to publish all the stuff
you've been doing about some what
amounts to calculus and and thinking
about Celestial mechanics and so on and
that's what became in 1687 Newton's
principia Mathematica uh mathematical
principles of a natural philosophy
um
uh Flo asks is the is the motion of the
Moon measurable compared to human
history
um certainly not by the naked eye
um it's uh it's a small effect and I
don't know whether well let me see
um
uh
uh I don't know whether since telescopes
were invented I I doubt that you can
tell it but the telescopes that you know
the span of the invention of the
telescope was 1608 or so
um and to now I don't think that's
that's measurable visually I mean the
the the the position of the moon is
known very accurately
um particularly because of the lunar
laser retro reflector left by the Apollo
Astronauts on the moon it's a it's a
thing that's like a street light the
street sign basically it has these
little well they're not so little in the
case of the Luna laser retro reflector
but um they're these little glass beads
spherical glass beads where light comes
in it's totally internal reflected and
it goes back out the same way like a
mirror but does better than a mirror
um and uh so when you shine a laser at
the Moon you shine laser pulse at the
moon and you do timings of how long it
takes to reach the Retro reflector and
come back
um the position of the moon is known to
within millimeters maybe now I think
it's one part from 10 to the 15. and so
I'm I'm sure you can see the the
receding of the Moon in that detailed
data uh from the lunar laser retro
reflector but I I don't think it's it's
I really doubt it's visible in in the
way that one could have got in the in
the 400 years or so of of telescopic
observations
uh
let's see
uh Jr asks how will history be able to
correct the continuous conundrum of the
accuracy of forefathers discoveries
inventions ideas how can we preserve
this I think maybe what you're asking is
um
the
people get things right people get
things wrong what's Remembered in
history and do we get to learn from the
the mistakes of intellectual history as
we might hope we could learn from the
mistakes of of things like
socio-political history
um you know I I must say that it's
always uh you know I'm a something of an
Enthusiast of History
um and um it is it is remarkable the
extent to which history sort of repeats
itself I mean I'm always interested when
when there are things about technology
and what's happening now and what what
are these companies going to do how's
this technology going to develop it's
like let's look at an analogy let's look
at how this relates to something that
came before you know let's look at the
fact that you know people at electricity
for 60 years or something and they had
always thought that it would be possible
to transmit the human voice over an
electrical line and hear it at the other
end but only when Alexander Graham Bell
came along
um in the
1870s did that did that finally with
surprised that actually start to work
and that's you know that's a very much
an analogy to what's happened with
machine learning a neural Nets of you
know when we will have a fluent kind of
uh producer of English essays which we
have now with Chachi BT when would that
happen when would the Alexander Graham
Bell moment for neural Nets happen it's
a very much analogous kind of thing and
again like the telephone where it was
really a question of oh you you as a
human were listening at the other end
could you understand what was being said
it's not a perfect rendition of you know
there's no there's no perfect answer of
what will well nowadays we know a little
bit better with signal processing and so
on what will it take to be able to have
the speech be comprehensible at the
other end but it was something which in
those days it was kind of much more of a
a we don't really know what's going to
make the speech comprehensible we're not
going to be able to get every detail of
the waveform which parts of it are going
to be important same thing with chat gbt
are we going to be able to get the big
picture of how the English text is
produced but you know I think uh it's
like you know the statement that's often
made about political history you know
history is written by The Victors
um you know when things have happened
and it's all quite messy and then in the
end it's the Glorious Revolution of some
kind and then the victors take over and
you don't hear about kind of the
messiness and and what was on the other
side and so on that does happen quite a
bit with scientific history and
technological history of you know you
only remember the the stuff that was
right you don't remember the stuff that
was wrong I think that it is very
educational to understand what was wrong
and sometimes the herd of scientific or
intellectual kind of belief very much
went in the direction of something it
was just complete nonsense
and um you know I think we will see that
we'll see that in all sorts of places
um where
kind of the oh I mean one there are
several that I personally been deeply
involved in I mean one is the continuity
of space something's been believed for a
couple of thousand years but it almost
got to the point around uh the beginning
of the 20th century where people said no
no space is going to be discreet but it
wasn't quite ready at that point but
then by the time we got to the uh I
don't know the beginning of the 2000s
for example uh it's like yup space is
discrete space is continuous say say you
know sort of most essentially all
working physicists how can it be
anything other than continuous we know
space is continuous we know it's
continuous since Euclid
um and uh turns out that's not true and
that's something which uh kind of was
was a was an incorrect kind of heard
belief that um that persisted for a long
time I mean I I kind of um uh you know
the the the realization that Euclid's
fifth postulate the fact that parallel
lines don't cross wasn't right and that
that could be something relevant to the
Theory of physics which is what Einstein
realized in 1915 with general relativity
and curved space and so on that the the
the incorrectness for the physical world
of Euclid's fifth postulate is what led
to general relativity what I realized is
that the very first thing in Euclid the
very first Common notion a point is that
which has no part rough translation from
Greek
um the uh uh a point there is the notion
of an indivisible point and you can kind
of densely put them in space that's
wrong
uh just like it will be wrong for uh for
something some fluid like water there
isn't a piece of water at every Point
there's molecules dotted around and so
it is with with the structure of space
and yes it will be 2 000 years that
people have sort of not not realized
that I think it's now pretty clear from
our physics project that that's the way
things are going to go I think it will
be super exciting and I'm hoping the
next few years this will happen that we
will actually see experimental evidence
of the discreteness of space and then
it'll be like uh then after that when
that history is Rewritten there will
come a time when nobody kind of nobody
discusses the fact that for for you know
20 centuries people were convinced that
space is continuous and in the last
century quite quite intensely so
um and that will be gradually forgotten
I suspect just as well for example a
good example of studying recently is the
theory of heat the caloric theory of
heat the idea that heat is a fluid that
suffuses substances nobody's heard of
that theory today they've heard of
calories because that was a word derived
from the caloric theory of heat but the
caloric theory of heat is not a thing
that is discussed or taught or whatever
today it was a wrong Theory and it is
interesting to analyze that theory it's
interesting to see the kind of analogies
of that theory with for example my
favorite is dark matter where people say
there's something funky about the
rotation curves of galaxies there's
something funky about the way the
gravity acts and galaxies oh it must be
particles because that's the only thing
people have seen that affects gravity is
the presence of matter and particles and
so on and and so you know I think dark
matter just like it turned out heat was
a feature of of the structure of matter
you know the motion of molecules and so
on that wasn't imagined at the time when
all you knew about was sort of fluids
suffusing things so similarly dark
matter I think is the same type of story
it really isn't part articles it's
something about the structure of space
some feature of the structure of space
and perhaps the discrete structure of
space that we haven't known before
uh
let's see
all I was asking how did early
civilizations explain supernovas did
they understand it was a star exploding
had they come to this conclusion they
absolutely did not know it was a star
exploding absolutely not I I don't think
gosh I don't know what they said I mean
there are sort of somewhat apocryphal
stories
about eclipses which were another
bizarre thing because eclipses are
pretty rare on the earth because of the
the the Earth the orbit of the moon is
tipped relative to the orbit of the
Earth around the Sun the moon doesn't
line up with the sun very often it only
does it in in very occasional times when
it happens to the sort of when when the
stars line up more or less well the moon
and the sun line up but it's a rare
thing on other planets because the the
plane of the rotation of the moons is
not so different from the plane the
rotation of the planet around the Sun uh
there will be sort of eclipses much more
often although they won't be as dramatic
as eclipses on Earth because the the the
disc of their moons is not nearly as big
relative to the disk of the Sun from
their surface but any case the the um uh
uh you know there's a there's a story
that thales
um one of the um uh early Greek perhaps
the earliest Greek scientist of uh was
um uh predicted the eclipse that would
happen in a battle between Greeks and
Persians I think and um the the while
the battle was going on Thalia said
there's going to be an eclipse and all
these people were were out battling with
each other and then the sun got covered
and everybody freaked out and they said
you know we're the they ran away from
the battle
um and so people gave uh you know at
least in the the story is that was
predicted by thales now what he probably
did predict are these things called
Soros Cycles which are the times when
eclipses can happen there are certain
times when eclipses can happen and
others when they cannot it is not
guaranteed for the Earth that an eclipse
will happen at every point at every sort
of piece of the sorrow cycle but
eclipses can happen then and that's
probably what he knew about we know for
example the anticothera device from
around 0 BC a little mechanical computer
that we have that did have a
representation of Saros Cycles so that
was a known thing maybe not in the time
of thales obviously but I I'm not I
would not be surprised but Bailey's knew
about that I think yeah and in fact
Ptolemy knew about it as well because in
ptolemy's um uh um Almanac he discusses
uh the kind of you know in those days
people would talk about astronomy and
they would prove theorems about
astronomy so for example Ptolemy proved
the theorem that they cannot be more
than what is it five eclipses in a year
I think that that purely by the geometry
of the Earth and the moon and the and so
on there can't be more eclipses than
that now Ptolemy was operating on a a an
earth-centric system where everything
went around the earth rather than going
around the Sun but the theorem about
eclipses doesn't depend on that in fact
very little depends on that it's really
just a change of coordinate system to
say things are going around the Sun
rather than the Sun is going around the
earth at the time of Copernicus that
seemed much more striking but in terms
of the mathematics it's not as different
um the
in any case I think um uh
let's see so
um I think they
by the time of Ptolemy they didn't know
what eclipses were I think in the time
of thales maybe 5th Century BC or more
um they didn't know what what I don't
think they knew what was going on on our
Clips
um I think that I mean thales had this
theory that it's often quoted as
everything is made of water which sounds
kind of silly but the very non-silly
thing that he concluded was maybe in
fact the world is made of discreet
things like atoms Democritus and the
epicureans were the real ones who talked
about atoms but the world is all made of
different configurations of the same
thing and that's what we now believe
from our physics project of sort of it's
all hypergraphs and atoms of space and
that's sort of a one thing that
everything in the world is made of and
that's something paley's figured out
in terms of supernovas the the Supernova
of 1054 was observed I think it's
recorded in in Chinese
um uh sort of government literature
um and uh I
I forget they had a name for it
um guests star perhaps something like
that uh they had a name I don't think
they knew at all what it was
and the concept of stars as being
something like our sun
um that was a thing that people were
talking about for sure by the 1500s
1400s certainly by the 1600s I think
Giordano Bruno who came to a very sticky
end at the at the hands of uh uh the the
Catholic Church actually
um was notably uh notable for having
said that yes the stars are like the Sun
but far away and I don't think that was
a I'm not sure that was a known
gosh was that something that was talked
about in Antiquity I'm not sure don't
know
um but the notion that a star could
explode as opposed to you know the fixed
Stars which were in fixed positions and
everlasting Stars I think it was will be
sort of shocking that the idea that a
star would explode now when did
supernovas get understood
um novas just sort of a star absorbing a
bunch of gas and sort of belching it out
those were I think I mean those those
were well studied by the early part of
the 20th century
um supernovas sure
it's the first one that was observed
through telescopes so it's a good
question I'm not sure I know the answer
to that the study of supernovas and how
they work
um was a thing of kind of the 1960s I
would say the notion that stars were
powered by nuclear fusion had to wait
for people to understand nuclear fusion
that was the 1940s soon thereafter
people understood that stars were
powered by nuclear fusion people hadn't
known what powers the stars and once
that was known the idea that there could
be a catastrophic collapse of a star and
a supernova that was a thing known by
the 1960s and but then the question of
computing the details of supernovas that
was a big complicated mess because
supernovas are complicated they involve
many different uh isotopic species many
different types of atoms they involve
nuclear reactions they involve so the
probabilities of different kinds of of
atoms colliding a lot of those things
started to be measured
um in the 1940s in connection with
particularly the nuclear weapons program
and what what ended up happening by the
9 1970s there was kind of the same kind
of calculational methods that were used
to calculate nuclear weapons explosions
were the ones that were going to be used
to calculate Supernova explosions and
there was typically a parallel sort of
track at the U.S National Labs there was
interest in like at Los Alamos National
Lab there was interested in supernovas
and there was interested in interest in
in nuclear weapons and they were kind of
the same codes that were being used
because you needed to use the same
things and sometimes there's a lot of
complexity because some of the
measurements that were being made of
nuclear cross-sections probabilities for
nuclear interaction were classified
because they were relevant for figuring
out things about nuclear weapons and so
you kind of maybe maybe sort of couldn't
or could use them for for Supernova
codes the other big problem was for a
long time people would compute
supernovas this was still happening in
the 1980s people could compute uh sort
of the collapse of a star the the
ignition of you know oxygen burning
silicon burning these kinds of things
where you start getting these extra
nuclear reactions happening and by golly
according to those calculations Stars
wouldn't explode
and that was that was kind of
embarrassing because uh what happened in
the 80s in the early 80s the nuclear
Test Ban Treaty came in and that had a
big effect on what one could do in terms
of nuclear weapons because before that
time you would you know dig this hole in
the Nevada desert or in the 1950s you
would go to some island in the Pacific
and you would detonate a nuclear weapon
and you would see what happened and you
would put all kinds of instrumentation
you'd measure all kinds of things you'd
know if we built a bomb this way it
would blow up
and you had reasonable confidence with
that but by the time the Test Ban what
was that 1984-ish or so was in place by
the time the Test Ban came in you
couldn't do those tests in the US and so
on anymore and and so that meant that it
was really important that you'd be able
to calculate will this will this bomb
actually blow up or not and and so then
it became really a a critical thing
because the same code was being used to
compute would supernovas explode and it
said they wouldn't
and so what really happened well they're
very complicated codes and I think in
the end
um and this is one of these stories
which I really should check more
carefully and it's something I've heard
from from multiple people who were
involved and I haven't completely
triangulated about about the accuracy of
this but I believe that what in the end
came to life is that some neutrino
opacity data cards have been mistyped
and that that was why the uh the
conclusion supernovas don't happen was
uh was was come up with and once that
was corrected supernovas Could Happen
according to these codes now it's a it's
a messy situation because we know
supernovas happen so if you run this
code and it says supernovas don't happen
you go keep searching for a bug until
you find out that they happen once you
find out they happen you say great
supernovas happen we're done you don't
go searching for other bugs so I'm not
sure exactly how that's how that's kind
of validated
um but that's kind of the modern version
of of sort of The Happening of
supernovas there are still other kinds
of mysterious things you know that the
blazars and the the gamma ray bursts and
so on where one's only just starting to
have some idea of what those might be
and quasars for example quasars were
discovered in the
1950s I think
um and uh you know very bright radio
galaxy in the and yeah they must have
been 1950s because that was after the
discovery of radio the invention of
radio astronomy by by jansky and people
um the uh
uh very kind of intense uh you know
galaxies where you know people the
original theory for what quasars were
was they were probably anti-galaxies
annihilating with galaxies because
people didn't know it wasn't clear until
the well beginning of the 80s actually
that the Universe didn't have equal
amounts of matter and antimatter but
just separated into different Pockets
that became clear well by even I worked
on this and the at the end of the 70s
beginning of the 80s
so
um
herb asks
saying the stars are like the Sun but
far away
uh when that was said for the first time
other people must have thought that was
crazy
um
how often were ideas like this
disregarded at first and how do
researchers convince Society of their
findings I mean the history of science
is full of people realizing things and
nobody believing them whether it's the
existence of germs whether it's the uh
you know the fact that the stars are
like the sun whether it's lots of these
things it's uh uh you know what people
say
I I remember I was asking the chap who
who um uh invented the idea of a solar
wind which was observed by by early
satellites and I asked him
um a person named Parker what's his
first name forget
um the um
um uh
you know what did the people who didn't
believe in the solar wind and the
emission of particles from the Sun what
did they say after satellites observed
this
he told me they finished that careers
still believing it wasn't really there
in other words people have a certain
mindset and once people are invested
enough in that mindset there's a there's
a terrible tendency for them not to
change I mean it's one of these things
where uh you know if we achieve human
immortality one of the biggest risks is
that no new idea will ever come up
because it's kind of like people are set
in this kind of this is the way it has
to be and this is the way I have
conceptualized it and it won't change
you know I have to say in my own life
I've been lucky enough you know I've
probably been doing science now close to
half a century and um there are things
that I have kind of realized have to be
the case and most people are like no no
no that couldn't possibly be like the
importance of kind of you know the
computational underpinnings for physics
people for decades were like no no no
that couldn't possibly be the case I
think now finally we're getting to the
point where people say okay okay that's
probably right
um what has gotten us to that point
it's a a complicated mixture of kind of
ambient thinking about related things
sort of problems with other approaches
sometimes you'll have the killer
experiment that just says this is it
this is how it works you know it has to
be that way but actually the killer
experiment is not as convincing as it
often seems to be like the mentioning
the solar wind case where there was a
killer experiment and people still
didn't believe it in other words people
can always have you know the experiments
are hard to do sometimes they're
incorrectly done at first Sometimes they
validate a theory it turns out to be
wrong sometimes they're validated theory
that turns out to be right but you can
always kind of explain away some parts
of these experiments I mean you know we
can see that a lot with biomedical
research and I don't know you you go to
Modern Times And you know does the
vaccine work does it not work does it do
this does it do that you know all these
kinds of things it's complicated it's
complicated to say you know to make the
measurements to make the conclusion you
know how do you do it what's what's what
assumptions do you make what uh you know
how do you slice the data and so on it's
complicated and in the end a lot of
these kinds of things are a matter of
kind of collective belief more so than
they're a matter of the experiment
another thing that can happen is that
you can have something where the theory
you know there's a there's a rough Edge
there's something about it that we
really can't explain but the theory is
so successful that people say oh yeah
yeah we we believe in that theory even
though there's this nasty rough Edge in
some corner where where people can't
really quite explain that and they kind
of wave their hands a bit about that but
the rest of the theory is so compelling
and so successful that you go go for it
but yeah I mean it's it's kind of a bad
story in the in the um uh
you know in in Past Times particularly
with uh sort of I would say Many
religious Traditions particularly I
would say perhaps uh you know
historically in in West kind of the
Catholic tradition of uh uh you know
there is a theory of the world and it's
what's in the Bible type thing and and
that which deviates from it is is heresy
and sort of bad things happen to people
who are the Heretics kind of thing I
think to be to be fair I think that um
some of the uh in my own views some of
these kind of early theological views of
the world were more correct than people
might give them credit for they were
couched in terms that that are very
non-modern in the way that they talk
about things but some of the issues and
some of the kind of logical conclusions
that were made aren't as far off as
people might assume based on kind of the
layers of centuries of science that came
after them but I think that the uh uh
you know there was certainly a great 10
tendency to I mean I I would say that if
I'm to make a kind of social comment of
modern times the you know the big danger
in a lot of times is is this forcing of
of Orthodoxy so to speak and there is a
certain tendency in you know in areas of
Academia and other things like that to
sort of force Orthodoxy and that means
that in the light of History you're
saying like oh my gosh how could they
have missed that it was so obvious but
but the Orthodoxy was something
different and uh and there was kind of
the the societal pressure the human
pressure was such that the thing that
was actually turned out to be right in
the end was something that was was sort
of squashed for a long time and no one
sees this all over all sorts of
different areas of science
um
there's a question from Jamie here is it
possible errors and translation of
affected results or research other
examples of this in history you know one
fun example that I know
is some
uh some names the sine function sin and
cosine function I believe those were
uh yeah there was the notion of a chord
and a circle piece of a circle where you
take the chord at you know just the line
across the circle and then you have the
Arc Length around the chord and we still
have things like arc sine but then we
have the measurement of the length of
the chord that was kind of this issue of
given a circle how long is that chord
that was something that was was
discussed by the Egyptians and um the uh
uh that length of the chord is related
to the sine function of trigonometry
um but there was a word for it in
Egyptian it was transcribed into Arabic
it was then mistransliterated into Latin
and that's how we ended up with the sine
function which was a mistransliteration
of an Egyptian word for chord
um and uh and then it was sort of burnt
into trigonometry by the 1500s by people
like Reggio montanus and so on who
developed what what we now consider to
be trigonometry although trigonometry
was known to the ancient Egyptians and
such like so that's at least one minor
example where that's happened
um I think you know there are many other
kinds of uh words made a theory type
thing I mean it tends to be the case
that having a word for something is very
important in developing a theory you
know there are words which were intended
to be pejorative so to speak like big
bang was a pejorative term for the model
of the universe in which the universe
started small there was a much more
popular steady state theory of the
universe in which the universe was just
hanging out there and Mata was being
added in places around the universe
leading to the expansion of the universe
and it was sort of a pejorative couldn't
possibly be true Big Bang idea of the
Universe
um that turned out to be the correct
idea as as uh has really got sort of
ratified when the cosmic microwave
background was observed in the early
1960s
um so there are cases like that I'm
trying to think about other
examples I mean one has to remember that
the transmission of knowledge went
through you know a lot of what we now
know as science came from you know
ancient Babylon the mathematical
Sciences ancient Greece and then it was
sort of transmitted a lot uh through uh
sort of Arab
um uh kind of civilization
um and uh so a lot got translated in
Arabic survived in the in the uh you
know Arabic tradition in in monasteries
and the equivalent and so on and then
eventually eventually got translated
back into Latin
um and and came to Modern Times And I'm
not immediately aware of of other cases
where somebody goofed by just sort of
mistranslating a word although I bet
there were some
uh
uh let's see
Aaron is asking what was the first time
anybody considered the angle of our
solar system relative to the galactic
plane well people certainly knew the
Milky Way the Milky Way you know
galactos
the word for Galaxies you know the
galaxos that is the word for milk in in
ancient Greek and so the Milky Way it's
you know Galaxy milk that's all a thing
now realizing that it was a Galaxy that
it was a configuration of stars and
knowing about uh galaxies other than our
own I believe that was beginning of the
20th century was where the first
observations of galaxies were the
Andromeda galaxy could be seen and
people could guess that that thing we're
seeing that spiral galaxy we're seeing
that's probably the Milky Way that we
see of stars that are in the plane of
our galaxy is probably a a reflection
for us of something like what we see in
the Andromeda galaxy I'm thinking that
was an early 20th century kind of thing
and as soon as you know that we are a
galaxy with a Plano Galaxy then you
start saying well what's the plane of
the Galaxy relative to the plane in
which we orbit the Sun
so I'm guessing early 20th century
uh
let's see
um
oh Pedro asked the question maybe um why
did science evolve so rapidly in the
western world that's a very interesting
question
um
you know what were the competitors I
mean there was kind of the Islamic world
the Chinese maybe Japanese maybe
um
these are all different Traditions they
have different traditions of of ways of
thinking about knowledge I mean let's be
realistic science didn't evolve rapidly
in the Western World until the
Renaissance I mean it was you know there
was a long period where when people said
we need to know about you know we need
to know about the world
what how do we know about the world how
where does knowledge come from it comes
from the Bible and from Aristotle those
were sort of two principal books that
were used in in sort of academic
teaching for a thousand years and uh the
concept that new knowledge could be
created wasn't obvious the concept that
new knowledge was was something that
could readily happen and that we weren't
really just looking to the ancients for
knowledge
um the uh you know that was a thing that
um uh you know that was a real meta
realization new knowledge can be created
now that was a that's in what is sort of
interesting about that is when it comes
to kind of religious belief that's
something where sort of the the uh you
know the forces of Orthodoxy will say no
no we don't want to create the new we
want to stick with the tried and true in
the case of the Western World perhaps
what's in the Bible
and and and then but you know then we
have kind of oh we can have modernity
and we can have something where we
deviate from that you know people will
say the last hundred years uh you know
uh with the with Nietzsche's famous
quote you know God is dead and so on the
The key thing that came to be believed
is oh we don't need any of that stuff
that was in the Bible that stuff that uh
was you know religion offered we can
invent everything for ourselves that's
kind of the um in a sense that's the
that's the conceit of modernity we can
just invent everything for ourselves and
that's sort of been conflated a bit with
science will invent it for us you know
we can figure it out with science who
needs the ancient books to tell us how
things work
well obviously there are you know we we
see right now in thinking about AI for
example and you know here's a here's a
very quintessential issue of this type
we're trying to invent AI ethics we say
great let's use science to invent AI
ethics let's make a scientific theory of
AI ethics
well it doesn't work because ethics is
not scientific in that sense ethics is
not something that has a a sort of a
necessary formal structure it's not like
something like mathematics where you
sort of build it up now now in the case
of Ethics one of the things I've
realized recently actually is that one
of the features of science
is that it allows you to look at
subsystems of the world when we do
science when we look at the science and
mechanics we can say we have this
projectile it is in a vacuum it's not
subject to any external forces it's
moving in this way it'll obey Newton's
Second Law let's say we we can abstract
away a subsystem from the world we can
discuss this little sub piece of the
world and have a scientific narrative
about it independent of everything else
that's happening in the world that
doesn't work with ethics when we say you
know we're doing one of these trolley
problems and we say do we pick five
llamas or you know one rhinoceros and
how do we pick which one which one will
be you know which one will we kill with
this trolley problem kind of uh ethical
weighing decisions well that question
doesn't really have an abstracted answer
we could say well we can look at the DNA
of the llama and the DNA of the
rhinoceros and this and the other but
that's not really the point in the end
that ethical question ties itself up
with the complete story of of what our
civilization talks about it's kind of
interesting that an llm large language
models the chat gbt world that's a case
where we are taking the complete sort of
story of our language and we're
encapsulating it up into this thing it's
very similar to what's happening when we
talk about things like ethics and we say
we're taking sort of everything that
goes on in the world and we're packaging
it all up into this one question of you
know five llamas or one rhinoceros and I
think that's a but I think that the the
traditions of science don't end up
saying that much about kind of how
ethics works we can formalize some
aspects of Ethics we can kind of use
logic a bit but in the end ethics is
this kind of thing that comes from all
the different parts of our civilization
uh sort of all impinging on that one
decision that you're making very
different from science and so when we
ask the question well where do we look
for our sort of uh sort of uh our kind
of conceptual foundation for ethics I
don't think we get to say let's look at
mathematical science for example that's
not a good basis for that really that's
a place where we're reflecting back to
earlier kinds of thinking like
theological kinds of like the kinds of
thinking that theologians did for a long
time uh you know theologians were the
main intellectuals for many many
centuries so that's where the
intellectual work got done that
intellectual work that predates modern
science is is some of what's needed
and thinking about these very modern
questions about things like AI
governance and so on so I think it's
it's a uh but in any case that's to say
that for a very long period of time
there was a lot of pressure even in the
Western World to not try and invent new
knowledge because in sense inventing new
knowledge is to go beyond uh people
thought about it I don't think it's
really a correct interpretation but but
to invent new knowledge it's kind of to
go beyond God to somehow say we are you
know we are more than we are you know in
the God is dead type quote we are we can
create for ourselves independent of of
the the kind of uh the universe that's
out there the the kind of this the god
that's out there so to speak we can just
invent everything for ourselves there is
no uh the the humans have triumphed we
can invent anything we want we don't
have to go with the kind of uh
Traditions which happen to be written
down a long time ago in religious texts
and so on but which were the the kind of
the long traditions of our civilization
so you know what happened in the 1400s
and so on as the Renaissance happened
and uh you know what led to that kind of
flowering of of possibility you know I
think there are a lot of details that um
are to do with political history as much
as anything else
um and uh uh that um you know it
probably helps to have some peace time
it helps to have a certain degree of of
sort of uh uh Leisure Leisure kinds of
uh things where where you know it isn't
the case that everybody at the age of
whatever has to go off and fight a war
you know people can have some chance to
kind of uh just Ponder things and so on
but that hasn't been true and I mean I
suppose in ancient Athens for example it
was also a fairly uh for good or bad
reasons it was a fairly prosperous place
where people could just kind of uh you
know lounge around and think about
things and debate things it wasn't like
you know all hands to the war or all
hands to making food
um so I think you know that that helps I
I think that uh
this notion of you know can one invent
the new is that something that is part
of the cultural tradition that's a very
important thing and it exists in some
cultures doesn't exist in others I think
it is something that is all too easily
extinguished because I think the natural
tendency of our species particularly
when we build larger larger
organizations and institutions is to to
force everything in the same direction
to have this kind of industrial flow of
things that's much easier it's a much
easier thing to manage if you're you
know let's keep this country under
control much easier if everybody's kind
of uh sort of going in the same
direction than if it's like lots of uh
lots of prima donnas all sort of
concluding oh no actually we'll think
about this different thing Etc et cetera
et cetera so in terms of sort of the
societal structure and societal uh kind
of um uh you know keeping a society from
going crazy yeah it's a good strategy to
just get everything to go in one flow in
terms of inventing the new and making
sort of further progress in the world
it's not a great strategy but I think uh
you know I think there have been these
these few cases where you can see you
know in in in Britain you know at a time
when it had its Empire and it was all
very you know very plush
um you know there was lots of
intellectual kind of a lot of
intellectual energy sort of started
emerging often on the part of people who
in a sense didn't have to uh you know
didn't have to quotes work for a living
so to speak and could really Ponder
these more intellectual kinds of things
and there are plenty of examples of
people who did do some you know work for
a living they they worked for the
foreign office or something in the in
the in the UK but they were stationed in
some some random part of the world and
they studied the local language the
local culture et cetera et cetera et
cetera and wrote lots of things about it
and and so on and did what would now be
considered sort of academic work on that
but I think this is uh
um you know it's a feature of of uh uh
it's always this this interesting time
when the new has happened when something
new has opened up and then there's the
possibility of of can that be pursued
and it is a terrible mistake when people
say uh you know the new has opened up
let us kill the new and you know that's
a way in which sort of uh intellectual
history gets set back by centuries now
having said that we kind of we can
invent everything we can do everything
will make arbitrarily weird nasty um you
know I don't know we'll construct every
possible virus we'll do this we'll do
that uh you know all of these things
that um you know there are things where
or we'll we'll do these things where we
uh sort of Let's test this particular
hypothesis that well yes it might wipe
the species out but you know and anyway
we'll test it as a matter of science you
know some of these things are are
obviously bad ideas and some of the some
of the things we can do you know there
are a lot of issues in in sort of ethics
of of biology and Medicine you know do
we make the Clone humans do we do do we
allow you know the cloned organs do we
do we do these things that will have
this effect do we have you know this and
that and the other there are things
where there's a sort of a question and
yes in principle we can do these things
is it a good idea how does it relate to
the the Global Ethics the full structure
of our civilization that's what we kind
of have to be thinking about and it's
something that science has rather little
to contribute to it's not to say that we
should just sort of throw science out
and ignore it but one should recognize
that there are plenty of things in the
world where it doesn't help one terribly
much and you know this phenomenon that I
talk about a lot of computational
irreducibility where you ask the
question you know given that you know
the scientific Rules by which something
operates does that mean you can say
everything you need to say about that
thing and the realization of modern
times I mean this is you know last I
mean I started talking about
computational irreducibility in 1984-ish
um but uh boy that's ironic in some ways
um in any case I never realized that
before
um in any case in the in the um
the celebration of 1948 that was George
Orwell's 1984 and its kind of Notions of
the structure of uh uh that the concept
of computational irreducibility should
happen to have originated in that year
is kind of interesting because
computationally reducibility is the way
in which kind of science from the
insides of science from the hardest
science you can get kind of says science
is limited in what it can say it kind of
says there are these there's this sort
of irreducible barrier to knowing
certain kinds of things in science and
that realization that computational
irreducibility is this barrier to
knowing things in science that is not
yet understood I mean it's understood by
some people and uh you know I've
certainly been yakking about it for for
35 years
um more than that nearly 40 years now
um and uh and and there's there's some
emerging knowledge I certainly notice
among young scientists that I work with
that a decent fraction of them take
computational irreducibility for granted
um even though you know when I first
introduced it it was like how could this
possibly be true type thing but it's
something where you know as that gets
absorbed as the idea that you can know
the scientific rules and not be able to
predict the outcome as that gets really
absorbed that is a a blemish a kind of a
a limitation that one realizes of
science that it isn't the case that you
know the last 300 years it's been like
if we can make it into a science if we
can make it into a mathematical type
science we got it nailed we know
everything well no that's not true and
in fact from within the science itself
it's telling you that there's that issue
so that kind of makes one a bit more
humble about what science might be able
to provide and it makes one a bit more
humble about kind of what you know we
humans can just invent whatever we want
and conclude things because science is
backing us up well science isn't
necessarily backing us up because
Sciences is unable to make those
statements it's unable to tell us no
this this sort of system of AI ethics or
something there's never going to have
any problem type thing so I think that
that's some uh
yeah that's that's my view of that
um
uh
let's see is that but but this question
about when does science evolve rapidly
and why did it evolve so rapidly post
Renaissance in the Western World
fascinating question and I think it's I
think there's a lot of coincidences of
History A lot of these moments when
there is a fertile moment when things
can really advance I mean you see that
it's usually this sort of usually a
methodological advance and
instrumentation some idea but it's also
can be the ambient uh sort of
environment of society it's like we've
got new stuff going on now one of the
things that's really interesting about
llms and the chat GPT story and so on is
this is a wake-up call new stuff can
happen that we didn't expect and I think
that we will see uh we've already
started to see but we'll see more of it
of gosh golly you know let's re-examine
this because something really new might
happen in this area once there's been
one new thing it's kind of like it
almost infects other things with the
possibility of newness so to speak I
mean it's kind of like you know there
were places where nobody ever did a
startup company but then somebody does a
startup company and Country X and then
people realize well it's actually
possible to start a company and to to
make something from nothing in that way
they think that's a you know this
contagion from one new idea to others is
an interesting phenomenon I don't know
how well that's been studied but I I
suspect we're going to see that we are
already perhaps seeing that in the kind
of AI advances that are happening now
not only is it oh let's look at AI but
let's look at all these other things as
well and and and they may seem less
surprising
so
uh
Beatty says what's there to say about
alchemy in history
um
you know Alchemy turned into chemistry
basically I mean Alchemy was the attempt
to you know make gold out of lead Etc et
cetera et cetera but it was all sort of
mixing up things and seeing what would
happen quotes chemically and that really
turned into chemistry and you know one
of the things that that happened was
there was a certain mathematicization of
chemistry that happened in the hands of
people like Dalton in the 1800s and and
many other people that that chemistry
became sort of quantitative in a way
that it hadn't been and as soon as we
understood about elements and limited
numbers of kinds of atoms that really
helped but you know at the time of the
Alchemists
chemistry was a narrative story of you
know you you stir up this and you do
that it was all words there was no
formalism of chemistry that's what
developed in the 1800s and that's what
allowed kind of modern chemistry to rise
out of the ashes of alchemy
um
spare parts asked is that because
ethical questions are fundamentally
computationally irreducible questions I
think often that they are I mean I think
that
that um
uh I think this idea and I have to admit
I'm only really trying to think this I'm
only really sort of been thinking about
this recently this idea that in ethics
you can't break off subsystems is an
important concept and that ethics is the
story of how everything we think affects
what is going to happen
and I think also computational
irreducibility and its role in ethics
for example the trolley problem thing of
you know you um uh
um the the person who invented that
problem fill up a foot was a was a
philosopher in Oxford who uh was
actually a friend of my mother's my
mother was a philosophy professor in
Oxford
um so I'm sure I met the originator of
the trolley problem at some point in my
my youth but didn't know it but anyway
the the um this concept of the trolley
problem might actually be an ill-formed
concept because kind of says oh you've
got this train car and it's going to go
this way or it's going to go that way
it's going to kill this
thing or that thing and which way do you
want it to go
well you know that sort of denies
computational irreducibility it implies
a kind of scientism of you know if you
make if you push this button if you move
this lever this will necessarily happen
because that is what science says will
happen but actually it might be more
complicated than that it might be that
um uh you know well there are these
chickens on one side and there's a
there's a Dodo on the other side and you
know the chickens are such that if the
trolley is coming right in their
Direction they'll jump out of the way
and the dodo won't and you know all
these kinds of things where you think
it's just a you know you move a level
one way you move it the other way you
know what's going to happen it's a
computationally reducible story but in
fact it might very well be the case that
there really isn't that when you try and
do this subsystem reduction thing which
is essentially what the trolley problem
is doing it's trying to take what is
otherwise the big entangled mess of
Ethics where everything affects
everything and it's trying to separate
it off into this one one specific
question that that idea of that
separation fundamentally doesn't work
and then how do you do this kind of you
know because science is about taking
what is out there in the world and kind
of stuffing it into our minds like
they're sort of slicing it down to the
point where we have something that will
fit in a human mind and that we can
reason about and and have a narrative
about so how do you take this thing the
fundamentally entangles everything and
how do you kind of stuff it into our
minds I think that's as I think about it
talking to you guys that's kind of in
some sense that can be viewed as a
fundamental problem of Ethics how do we
get to our principles that are
extractable in the subsystem kind of way
from this thing that is otherwise just
talking about every aspect of
civilization
and I think um
uh
let's see uh maybe one more thing here
and then I should should wrap up for
today
um
uh atori comments how do you filter out
the good news from the bad new it's
remarkable that old ideas stand the test
of time
yeah a really good question how do you
how do you uh figure the good news from
the bad new
then
you know sometimes
with technology let's say
there is a sort of de facto it was a
good idea by look it made a billion
dollar company
that's the de facto it was a good idea
actually it may have been a really bad
idea but it turned out that because of
forces of various kinds it may have been
an idea that is now you know when I say
a really bad idea I'm in a sense in
training some kind of ethical or value
system
which I'm not really accounting for so
you know it might have been an idea you
know you could say well let's look at I
don't know some
some
industrial idea and why I'm thinking of
you know watches radium dials that were
you know radioactive dials and so on
um that turned out a really bad idea but
they were commercially successful so you
might say that was a good idea except it
turned out to have a sting in its tail
that made it a bad idea but so you know
this question of of what
um you know in the case of Technology
the a a good idea is de facto an idea
that is commercially successful now in
the marketplace of of of ideas
intellectual ideas you could say the
same thing an idea that a good idea is
an idea that takes root and lots of
people talk about it does that make it
even though in retrospect we may say I
can't believe people had that idea you
know we take ideas like I don't know
let's say Eugenics for example is a is
people look back and they say I can't
believe people had that idea and uh
maybe that's not even the worst one
because there are ones where it's just
the the well uh the the I think somebody
mentioned here a biogenesis the idea
that um you know you have a bunch of mud
and life can crawl out of the mud even
though there was no life there to begin
with they didn't know about you know
little tiny maggot eggs and things like
this
um this idea that the living can come
from the non-living or just a whole
bunch of these ideas that did indeed
persist for a very very long time and
you know I think as a sort of at a
personal level I'm I'm kind of proud of
my record you know perhaps wood I don't
know of of not betting on the wrong
ideas you know I think I have a a long
record of actually having bet on the
right ideas and and having not kind of
um been LED too far down the Garden Path
of a wrong idea that uh that
nevertheless was popular I mean you know
I've been I've been saying saying you
know quantum computers as they're
defined aren't going to work I've been
saying since 1980 and um uh it's you
know that not to say that the physics of
how you do Computing not with
semiconductors isn't worth doing and not
to say that the formalism isn't
interesting but the actual look I've got
a branded quantum computer it really
works there are all kinds of reasons but
I don't think that's going to work and
it's not something I'm prepared to bet
on because I'm I'm pretty sure it's not
it's not really real a real thing and
people will look back and say oh that
was really a you know they really goofed
that up maybe some interesting science
came up I mean it's an interesting thing
like the caloric theory of heat that
turned out to be completely wrong was
what led to the second order of
thermodynamics what led to the idea of
efficiency of heat engines what led to
lots of things that were absolutely
right so a wrong Theory doesn't
necessarily have to begat kind of wrong
ideas after it you can have a a wrong
layer and then the right gets put on top
of the ROM but you know this question of
how do you tell what's a right thing
what's a wrong thing I'll tell you I
suppose my heuristic if I have one is
what were the foundations of that thing
what really are they and is there a a
piece of mysticism in the foundations is
it something where people say but of
course this or that we all know this or
that and you say well why is that true
and it's like uh well we all know this
or that very bad sign and you find that
in areas of Science and and I had that
experience many times of you'll you'll
run into sort of a world expert on this
or that and I suppose I'm I'm I'm the
obnoxious kind of drilling interrogator
of many of these things you know kind of
why do we know that you know how what
evidence do we have for that well
there's this or that does that really
show that you know what does it really
show and can you can you drill what
happens when you drill and and my my
observation is that when when you drill
it's solid it's probably true when when
you drill you end up at the the mystical
moment
then it's probably not true might be
true but it's but you don't really know
and I think that's um that if anything
is is kind of a a uh a test but you know
honestly the the when people are
embedded in a flow of some particular
area nobody drills to the foundations
people are just doing you know most of
science for example consists of people
making incremental progress basically
which is sometimes important sometimes
not so important
um that's based on this existing Tower
that's been built and people just kind
of uh uh sort of building the next step
on the tower and asking what the
foundations of the tower are that's not
for us is the typical statement of of
many people in many most areas of
science so that means when you don't
look at the foundations well by golly
they could be really rotten
um but you wouldn't know it and and it's
not the day job you know the daily job
of the scientist isn't really to look at
that uh often in areas of science people
say why are you wasting your time on the
foundations you know that's not that's
not what the the actual practice of that
field is consisting of
anyway a lot of interesting questions
here well thank you all for that and um
uh I think I must run along talking of
day jobs to uh my day job and uh I think
I'm doing some things to do with llms
here talking of uh talking of modern
times and talking of kind of the uh the
the fertile moment that we're in with
respect to Ai and so on all right well
thanks for joining me here and uh see
you another time
bye for now